esta iniciativa fue presentada en la
legislatura anterior por un partido
digamos ahora acusado de tener vínculos
delincuenciales y del crimen organizado
el partido todos y es simplemente una
ley que pretendía ganar votos de
clientelares para beneficio particular
esta iniciativa fue apoyada por el
gobierno por el presidente ya más de la
campaña electoral buscando esos votos y
es una iniciativa
inconstitucional ilegal en el sentido de
que no hay nada que obliga al estado en
resarcir a militares que estuvieron en
el conflicto y se ha vuelto el mal
manejo de esta crisis que abona a que
estamos en medio de una crisis política
de gobernabilidad y estamos en medio de
más de una conflictividad ya delitos
cometidos contra el congreso a la
república
destrucción de bienes públicos es decir
la ha escalado la violencia a partir de
algo que tiene como origen una
iniciativa que pretendió y pretende
tener este sector social he convencido
de que deben apoyar a ciertos partidos
no no hay ninguna
obligación del estado de hacer esto y
además
es
imposible que el estado pueda resarcir
con los fondos que éste está
diciendo estos tres militares además de
los antecedentes que menciona la nota
inicial de que es un ejército que
violentó los derechos humanos